[Musique]
cani canyon marcellines mais famille
d'accueil depuis 18 ans
[Musique]
il faut que om ses personnages il a
aussi personnes handicapées parce que si
et c'est pas de faire semblant d'aimer
il passe pas on passe pas les vrais pas
monteur m'a toujours aimé les
personnages et parce que quand même on
télécom y passer chez certains grands
même ils portent des cercles et deux
petits sauts de l'opposant parce que
j'avais monté l'escalier et puis après
m'être quoi la casse vite mon nom a
toujours aimé les personnes âgées et les
passes difficiles d'amazon qu'il faut
comprendre la zot pour prendre un temple
disputé avec zot
[Musique]
non même con
les a prises les pas bien se tirer la
bourre question il faut qu'on reste
calme
il faut que our est la cousine de son
compact n'est pas toujours facile vous
êtes donc il faut de temps en temps même
s'ils savent pas trop besoin de mille
feux zaki voix ou même un moment donné
il faut prendre un temps aussi
ce tout sa réalité pour aller faire un
petit peu l'accompagnement comprends
qu'on veut dire ou à sir un petit peu
avec d'autres discutent un petit peu
avec même si racontant les mêmes choses
tout le temps les pas grave
[Musique]
il faut que tu gardes le petit autonomie
des nanas le plus longtemps possible les
plus faciles à manier mafia mangeas ou
comme c'est sympa mais ils vomissent
teaser qui peut manger même s'ils
saluent un petit peu ils vont en anglais
ça parce que ce covenant on compte
aujourd'hui de mazen n'a pu sais pas
combien d'enfants qu'ils demandent c'est
pas le contraire
s'ils me tire ça aujourd'hui demain et
bien plus
[Musique]
on a besoin des gens comme vous pour
faire ce travail pour occuper des
personnes âgées et des femmes est
d'accord mais pourquoi nous le travail
les ports reconnu pourquoi nous a pas le
droit à l'assedic cotisent pas l'assedic
pour nous s'il une famille d'accueil
elle est malade le tanka travaille pas
belles à rien du tout les mêmes droits
que les autres travailleurs et pour
l'instant de ne pas reconnu il saman
comprends pas pourquoi